أعلن الدكتور أنتوني فوسي للتو
أنه سيتنحى عن منصبه في نهاية
العام وترك منصبه
كرئيس للمستشارين الطبيين للرئيس
وأيضًا مدير
المعهد الوطني للحساسية والأمراض
المعدية ، وهو الدور الذي شغله لعقود
تحت سن السابعة.  يوقع آرليت الرؤساء
على العيش مع المزيد في هذا arlet.
ما الذي تسمعه من البيت الأبيض
في هذا
الصدد ، أعلن الرئيس بايدن رحيل الدكتور
أنتوني فوسي في
بيان سابق اليوم بقليل بصفته أكبر
خبير في الأمراض المعدية في البلاد وكبير
المستشارين الطبيين للرئيس
بايدن يخطط للتنحي من
منصبه الحكومي في ديسمبر ، والآن
أصدر الدكتور أنتوني فوسي بيانًا
قال فيه اقتباسًا بينما
أنتقل من منصبي الحالي ، فأنا لا
أتقاعد بعد أكثر من 50 عامًا من
الخدمة الحكومية التي أخطط للمتابعة
المرحلة التالية من حياتي المهنية بينما لا يزال
لدي الكثير من الطاقة والشغف في مجال عملي ،
أريد استخدام ما تعلمته
كـ niaid direc  لمواصلة النهوض
بالعلوم والصحة العامة وإلهام
وتوجيه الجيل القادم من
القادة العلميين حيث يساعدون في
إعداد العالم لمواجهة تهديدات الأمراض المعدية في المستقبل
الآن يعرف الرئيس بايدن
الدكتور أنتوني فوسي منذ عقود من العمل
معه عن كثب عندما كان  نائب
الرئيس كما تعاملت إدارة أوباما
مع فيروس زيكا
والرئيس في بيان الدولة الذي
وجهه شكر فيه لفاوسي على عمله ، قال إنه
اقتبس من التزامه بالعمل
لا يتزعزع وهو يفعل ذلك
بروح لا مثيل لها
ونزاهة علمية بسبب العديد من الدكتور
فوسي.  تم إنقاذ المساهمات في
الحياة الصحية العامة هنا في الولايات
المتحدة وحول العالم ،
وقد عمل الدكتور أنتوني فوسي في
الحكومة لعقود حتى الآن في هذا المنصب
كمدير للمعاهد
الوطنية للحساسية والأمراض المعدية منذ
ما يقرب من 38 عامًا بدءًا من عهد الرئيس
رونالد  ريغان نصح الرؤساء
طوال تلك الفترة بالتعامل مع
أشياء مثل
فيروس نقص المناعة البشرية وباء فيروس زيكا إيبولا أيضًا ، لكنه
ارتفع حقًا إلى دائرة الضوء خلال
جائحة 19 عندما كان
يصطدم علنًا في بعض الأحيان مع الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب
فيما يتعلق باستراتيجيته ،
طلب منه الرئيس بايدن البقاء والآن نحن
يتعلمون أن الدكتور فوشي
سيتنحى في ديسمبر